yeah because we'd be hearing about all
those like Malaysian flights that just
disappear or something like well that's
because like they had a they had a
Chinese pilot and I heard that Chinese
Pilots aren't really good because they
can't drive
[Music]
everybody take this information with the
grain of salt there is a video but let's
just discuss it first but okay I want to
get my plane was crashed on purpose to
test which seats have the best chance of
survival oh no can we take a guess first
before we watch any of this video let's
go ahead and talk about what we think is
the best it's the wing I'm going in the
bathroom in the back
you're gonna be like this but there's
more walls and [__] and [__] what about
the pilot seat don't they gotta stay
alive no because we're already crashing
yeah so they let go and then they run to
the back
oh [__] they're first Dead let's talk
about I mean let's talk about it well it
depends on how it lands right it doesn't
that have to do with it like if it has
like this I think it totally depends on
how it lands bro gravity bruh you're
dying like this all right let's just say
but every single time we're playing even
lands it lands a lot that's because it's
control no like this like this like this
so let's just say it's live oh it's no
style I feel like if you're dying or
crashing your nose dive okay if it's
nose diving I think way in the back yeah
the bathroom now you're a giant
accordion right in the bathroom yeah
right nothing's tiny I'll just be like
this or you can sneak on top of the
toilet or would it be better if you jump
out last minute oh yeah because then
instead of being from here to here now
you just have to jump from here to here
how about that
no I mean if you do
I don't know 400 miles per hour into the
water I think you're dead you're dead
yeah drink you're dead have you seen
that
um one plane that went down in Hawaii
did we watch it here but the plane went
down in the water and you can see it hit
the water and everyone evacuating and
then it's like a whole process this oh
yeah some people like oh I remember that
yeah that was cool yeah and then one guy
swam to shore one lady was holding on to
the [__] balloon I think that's what
we call a lucky one but there's one
person started like because they
couldn't swim yeah because we'd be
hearing about all those like Malaysian
flights that just disappear or some [__]
and like well that's because like they
had a they had a Chinese pilot and I
heard that Chinese Pilots aren't really
good because they can't drive oh my God
where'd you hear that I freaking Laugh
Factory
in Monterey Park dude just drive around
for a bit I would yeah I would assume
also the back for sure though like it
ain't the front first class be done but
what about the cockpit aren't they gonna
they gotta stay alive man how
but that's like Captain's going down
with the [__] they need to design it
better do do Airline captains have that
same type of like honor and rigor
towards like being like captains of the
[__] they're going down
underrated movies you just [__] flip
it upside down yeah I'm drunk right now
I mean our life is in their hands I
don't think they have the same go down
with the ship yeah I just don't think
you can see and drive from the back so
they got to be in the front I think it's
more of a logical thing weather up there
why do sea captains have to go down with
the ship because that thing goes down so
slow yeah like they got time to swim
true I thought it's because there's not
enough like lifeboats for everyone well
that's a Titanic's fault yeah that's
true because the Titanic is every single
ship you're supposed to have enough
balls isn't it they think Titanic was
planned yeah they said it was yeah we
did a story did we do a whole story we
just talked about it did we did it was a
different switch with another boat from
the same RMS line and they were like you
know we ain't got no insurance on this
old ass junk so we'll call it I think
it's the back no matter what I think the
back because if it lands like this okay
then the force goes like this right it
rolls and if it goes like this then in
accordions I'm going right here then so
I think the back no matter what I'm in
the emergency seat roll in the middle
that's what I said that's what I was
thinking thank you Joe yeah I'm on top
of the Wings I'm going 20 back from that
not the butt butt but 20 back from you
and I hope we both make it buddy I hope
we both make it so the extra legroom on
Jet Blue like those ones no like a
little bit behind that so again you got
to take it with a grain of salt because
not every [__] plane crashes the same
way but let's go and watch this little
bit of a video I'm flying tonight dude I
do not want to cover this
oh [__] oh first class oh dude first
class is dead dude see I was flying
first whoever's in the wings dead dude
you're swinging Joe you're getting dust
in the eye dude they really crashed This
Plane oh I'm in the middle dude the
sound the [__] pilot is upside down
dude the sound is not the pilot went
upside down and curled no he ate his own
dick on that wait they crashed the plane
just for just for like experiments I've
always crunched up right now wait who
was flying it a [__] robot so
basically they uh an ex-con there's a
lot of songs because of like where they
had to do this type of testing and like
over certain areas had to be flown by
actual human but point is a human pilot
was flying initially and then uh jumped
out and then let a robot it was like a
Make-a-Wish kid who always wanted to be
a pilot Bane dude wow basically a remote
control pilot was able to take over
after that and then they cracked so the
pilot was also a skydiver kind of yeah
and this was specifically in uh Mexico I
believe because of the area that they
were allowed to do it so blah blah blah
blah but yeah
um based off of this test uh as you can
see uh the front and the pilot uh just
was obliterated yeah so that's most
likely going to happen on any nose the
wing saved the wing had you could call
it more of a 50 50.
when they looked at the evidence of uh
you know dummy passengers in the back
they had the most chance of like still I
was the guy in the bathroom the guy in
the bathroom also obliterated [__] yeah
he was covered in [__] but alive and
killed himself due to embarrassment what
happens if everyone's free-fallen and
everyone realizes okay whoever's in the
front plane is gonna be done so
everybody runs to the back and the plane
and playing
do you think you think it changes yeah
so it becomes butt first like this you
ever been on a plane that didn't sell
enough seats and they have to move you
around by weight that's scary as [__]
for real yeah it never happens bro I've
been on one of them little ones from
like San Francisco to Sacramento or
something they're like yeah we're gonna
need three people from the left on the
right I'm like I don't trust this [__]
they're like specifically the giant guy
hey Mr 200 pounder oh dude we're [__]
they do have to calculate though because
when I wrote a Cessna a small one he had
to get all of our weights and then see
if we can fit that's scary yeah that's
scary yeah dude those are scary but
they're they're fine I like them because
um you know when you're on an airplane
like a commercial we only have this much
to see the world yeah but on a Cessna
it's like you're in a Land Cruiser
you're like an SUV with Windows all over
so everywhere you look it's like you see
a beautiful view of everything I do want
to do one of those ones in like Alaska
and land on the water
planes that'd be so scary but it'd be
kind of sick yeah you could do that here
with a duck plane one the LA River
Landing right in the trees and cement
Park Lake yeah so uh again just to just
reiterate uh you wouldn't be surprised
to learn that people at the front of the
plane most likely die in a real crash
those who are seated over the wings of
the plane would most likely receive
survivable but serious injuries broken
bones and the like whereas most of the
test dummies in the back of the plane
remain intact meaning that most
passengers would or could have survived
uh it says however it's worth pointing
out that if the plane had crashed tail
first circumstances would likely have
been reversed really I know what I
thought it would roll like a like a step
like heel toe
the the test and be even worse on the
front see the wing is 50 50. because you
could go like this you could go like
this but you can't go like this but what
if it's flying like this yeah I wonder
if a tree
even when it flies like this it'll hit
the ground and then go into the nose
right oh like like a ninja star so it's
like this
so it's like this and then it goes
wink
yeah that was a terrible diagram
um the test also found that brace
position which is the subject of much
speculation apparently would likely have
prevented head and spinal injuries but
would have created more pressure on legs
which could have resulted in more
breakages there
that's what you got you put your feet on
the front chair like this I thought you
gotta look like no that'll Crush you
press it dude so when when it crashes
you just you press away that'll [__]
Crush you potentially not if you
practice have you guys seen the couple
months ago Hawaiian Airlines had mad
[__] turbulence that video was good
and people were recording inside the
plane and then the aftermath the
scariest [__] is it starts with like uh
one of the footages like it starts with
this guy's like foot and it goes up like
he's panning through and you look over
and there's a flight attendant there
just sitting down on you know like in
the back they have their own seats right
she's covered in blood blood on the
walls dude Blood on the walls and she's
looking just straight like she saw the
devil I'm driving home dude you guys are
[__] my [__] up I'm flying like three
and then there was there was one sorry
this is
from though she hit her everybody dude
everybody rocked people Everyone popped
up huh yeah there was one lady that hit
the ceiling bro like she was in the
aisle not wearing a seatbelt and then
she like the plane drops and she hits
the ceiling and that's all you see is a
quick clip of the somebody hitting the
ceiling and then fall falling down and
there's holes at the top because people
weren't wearing their seat belts so they
flew up right I hiked that thing in oh
yeah it is I'm a big dude Gravity Hurts
me neither
is it because from that video on I start
I even sleep with a seatbelt on in the
play now because like before I was like
yo what other plane's gonna crash into
me I don't need a seat belt
yeah but when I saw the turbulent [__] I
was like that's scary dude you better
leave your seatbelt on yeah and people
are screaming yeah oh geez I'm glad they
all made it damn the most scariest
turbulence I had was going to China oh
yeah Beijing turbulence man they don't
[__] around over the weather or what
it's like communist turbulence dude
you're just like what the [__] they're
like figure it out fun for yourself we
were going to uh Florida one time as a
kid I remember and uh I think Orlando
and we're landing and we're probably
like 15 minutes out and you get one of
these yeah yeah oh [__] and I'll look at
my mom and my mom's like uh next to some
dude and luckily for some reason that
dude's a pilot he's like it's all right
I think we just got hit by lightning it
happens sometimes whoa
like it's made to absorb that [__] or
something I don't know don't fact check
me what the that's crazy
like I was crazy Game Boy Graphics got
all good
Mario turned to color all of a sudden
your hair is all cool
laughs
[Music]